Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
A marshmallow has the shape of a cylinder
It has a diameter of 5 and a height of 3
A dessert is made with 24 marshmallows
The bottom layer consists of 3 rows of 4  marshmallows
The top layer consists of exact the same arrangement.
Marshmallows are placed on top of the bottom layer.
The dessert is completed
when chocolate is poured to exactly fill the gaps between the marshmallows.
This is a side view of the dessert,
Here's the top view of the dessert
Chocolate exactly fills the gaps between the marshamallows.
The question is,
What is the volume of chocolate?
This problem was asked to grade 12 students in Australia.
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching the video for the solution.
The main principle is that the
volume of the chocolate is equal to the area of the cross section of chocolate
times the height of chocolate.
The dessert consists of two layers of marshmallows,
each which have a height of 3.
The total height of the chocolate will therefore be 6.
So, the volume is equal to the area of a single cross section, times 6.
We can see the cross section from the top view.
This forms the shape of 6 different gaps between the marshmallows.
Each of the 6 gaps are identical.
We therefore can simplify this to say that the volume is equal to 6 times the area of a single gap,
multiplied by the height of 6.
So, the volume is equal to 36 times the area,
of the single gap between 4 marshmallows.
What is that area?
We start out
by having 4 marshmallows.
Each marshmallow has a diameter of 5,
which meas the circle has a radius of 5 halves.
We now draw a square that connects the center of these four circles.
The square side length consists of the radius of 2 adjacent circles.
The side length of the circle is therefore equal to the diameter of the circle.
So, the side length is equal to 5.
The area between the gaps
is equal to the area of this square,
minus the area of 4 quarter circles.
So we can write this as the
area of the gap is equal
to the area of the square
minus the area of 4 quarter circles.
Now, 4 quarter circles together make one whole circle.
the area of a circle is equal to 's' squared
and the area of the circle, pi r squared.
This means, the area of the square is equal to
25, and the area of the circle is equal to 25 pi divided by 4.
Therefore, the area of the gap is equal to the difference between these two areas.
We can substitute this back into our volume formula, and then simplify it
to get our answer that the volume is equal to
900 - 225 pi, which is approximately 193.1
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video! Please subscribe to my channel, I make videos on math and game theory.
You can catch me of my blog at ''MindYourDecisions'' which you can follow on Facebook, Google + and Patreon.
You can catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar
And if you like this video, please check out my books. There are links in the video description.